it was video R8 news now investigators
brought you here first now the company
that runs the RTC bus where man was
stabbed 33 times is reiterating
passenger safety 59-year-old Aaron Cole
charged with murder in the death of
30-year-old Dominique Lucas now our 8
news now investigators obtaining video
from the bus showing it here in the far
left lane this is going north on
Paradise Road the driver who called for
help did not open the doors though for
four minutes while that man was under
attack a spokesperson telling us more on
why today quote when the incident
occurred the driver couldn't let
passengers off because of the heavy
stream of traffic on the right for
passenger safety the driver needed to
negotiate two lanes of traffic to get to
the far right hand lane and then pull
into the curb to safely open the doors
end quote you can read that full
statement on our website at 8newsnow.com
and also inside our app